hi i'm christopher hine and today we're
going to be talking about
kodagash off a jab and why you should
never ever try to do it so
this concept of i'm going to do some
aikido off of boxing techniques is is a
ridiculous idea
um the the techniques we do in aikido
are not the system they're simply a
technique in the system and so i think a
lot of people believe that
they'll prove that aikido works and
they'll prove that the ikea techniques
are good if they could do them off of
boxing or they could do them off of
wrestling
this is a silly idea right we have
another simpler much much simpler answer
for boxing and wrestling in aikido than
trying to do kodigai shot of a jab so
i'm going to get josh out here we're
going to spend a bunch of time talking
to you guys about
what jabs and and boxing kind of strikes
are
and why um doing something like a coat
of geyser any kind of wrist technique
is a bad idea off of those and what you
actually should be doing
and then we're going to talk about why
you would actually need to do those
wrist techniques as well so
all those things are true you do need to
do risk techniques sometimes
there are techniques that you should use
uh in aikido to deal with boxing and
wrestling
and there are really good techniques
from other systems that should be used
to get someone with um who's trying to
box you
but but that's not the the general
interpretation that we're having so i'm
gonna get josh out here we're gonna go
to work josh
all right so first let's talk about what
would it look like if we did
colder guys off of a jab so throw that
punch and i'm gonna do coat of guys
okay so that's what it looks like so if
you're
excited you want to know what it would
look like that's what it would look like
if it ever happened ever
okay now i say it that way because i
think it is a really important thing to
understand here
which is kodage is not a good technique
to do off of any kind of straight
punch right so when i was doing
mixed martial arts and i was doing
boxing uh there were a couple
simple ways that i dealt with someone
throwing straight punches right
one way was to out box them right so if
i was a better boxer than them
i would out box them right so if we're
like this and josh is throwing jabs and
i can see him coming
i'm out boxing this guy right so that's
what i'm doing i'm just going to outbox
him i'm going to
use better boxing skills now if i'm
doing mma
and he's a better boxer than i am i'm
going to try to change the distances
right so if he's throwing a jab
i'm going to try to change the distance
now from this position a good rear
clinch position like this
i'm going to try and dump him or throw
him or choke him or whatever stuff i'm
up to right
that's what i'm going to do from this
rear position like this
so those are the two ways in mixed
martial arts or in boxing that you would
deal with
someone who's throwing jabs at you
you'll either outbox them if you're a
better boxer than them
if you are not a better boxer than them
well if you're doing a boxing match you
would lose but if you're doing mma
then you would try and change the
distance and the way you would change
the distance be real simple right so
if i'm throwing a boxing uh jab at josh
right so if i'm throwing that boxing jab
at josh
okay either josh is going to time it so
he can get under it or around it
okay then he's going to close the
distance on me and then from this
position
he can control me right and he's got
direct body control so that's a really
good thing to do
now if he is trying to do a kodakaishoff
of that and i'm throwing a proper jab
right which a proper jab goes out and
comes back that's what a jab does right
so he tries to snatch my hand this is
what's gonna happen and then he's set up
for a nice cross
right or overhand or whatever it is i'm
throwing okay so when
i'm throwing my jab my purpose in my
hand is to go
out and come back really fast all right
now
if you are someone who's real excited
about the concept of doing kodagash off
of a jab
you probably see that and you say ah i
am way ahead of you christopher hine
because i would never ever try to grab a
hand out of midair
what i would do is i would get to a
close position as you were describing it
mma
and then i would do my coat of geish so
let's see what that would look like if
josh threw a jab right
and i closed the distance right so i've
closed the distance here now
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to work my way around into this
position like this
and then i'm going to kodagush this guy
right so if you're really into
marshall aikido you're probably saying
that you know it's like no i would close
the distance the same way as they do in
mma
that's a that's a good way to get there
and then once that's i'm there
then i will throw my kodagaish now my
question to that answer is
why on earth would you ever do a code
guys
because it's so cool
so that's nice it's cool it's really
cool i agree it's super super cool
maybe no one else agrees that it's super
cool
but but it's super cool to do that the
problem with it is
while i'm working my coda guys why
doesn't this guy punch me with his other
hand
okay now we could say lots of things
like well if you use the right angle
or you could defend against that or all
kinds of stuff but
that getting to this closed position and
then working to the hand
and then trying to dump him with the
hand is way more difficult than going
here
picking him up and dumping him right way
simpler which is something we might see
in mma
just shoot in there dump him right
there's a number of
close quarter throws and take downs i
could use that would work
infinitely better than trying to throw
someone by their wrist
let's let's just think for a second what
throwing someone by the wrist means
it means that i'm going to hold his
wrist this tiny bit of his body
and then i'm going to throw his whole
body with his wrist
now you might say well christopher hine
in fact
this will hurt so much that he will fall
down and fly through the air
magnificently
now that might be true if he was real
scared of getting his wrist hurt or
something he might choose to jump over
but if he's a serious guy i could
probably break his wrist and he's still
going to pound me with the other hand
right he's got a broken wrist but he
still smashed me to death with that hand
and so why would i try to throw someone
here if i had a full body clinch like
this
now he can't hit me with his other hands
can't kick me can't do anything
and i can dump him right so that's a way
better way so something we learn in
greco-roman or something
would be a better style throw than
trying to do a code guys
okay now you might say all right but i
have not studied greco-roman wrestling
or mma
so for me i am an aikido guy and i do
aikido
all the time and because i do aikido all
the time then i want to do coda geishas
because that's what i'm trained to do
i'm superior at coding issues
i'm terrible at other kinds of throws
right
the problem is what you should do is
invest two months
in doing mma style clinch takedowns
because those two months
will make you way more successful than
10 years of trying to do kota guy shot
for that situation
the reason is the technique's just low
percentage quota guy she's a low
percentage throw for trying to throw a
guy
with his wrist right much higher
percentage to get a soup play or
something right to come and grab the guy
and throw this guy
much much better than trying to throw
him with his wrist
so so that's what my answers to all
those things would be okay
now let's look at what aikido answers
are to a jab so so that was why you
shouldn't try to do kodagai shaft of it
and so now you say but i'm an aikido
expert
and i don't want to go study uh mma or
anything else so what am i going to do
against very realistic attacks like jabs
let's look at what the jab does okay the
jab principally does
three things right so if i'm throwing a
boxing jab
i'm either making distance right so if
i've got long arms and i don't want this
guy getting close to me or
if we're in mma style situation and this
guy wants to clinch with me
i'm going to use that to push him back
so this is what i'm doing i'm pushing
him back with my jab right
so i'm keeping the distance i want okay
so that's one of the primary things i'm
doing so
if a boxer if you're ever facing a boxer
and they're using a jab
one of the reasons they might be using a
jab is because they're trying to make
some distance for themselves and set
their ideal distance right
i.e to box you right so if i'm a
long-armed boxer particularly
i want this guy just i want this guy
just about this range
now when i'm getting him at this range
that means if i'm a long-armed boxer
he's not getting me back
it means if he's a grappler and i'm not
a grappler he can't grapple me because
from here
you see hard for him to reach reach out
as far as you can look at that very hard
for him to reach and get me
so that might be a reason i'm using my
jab is because i'm trying to set
distance okay
another reason i'm going to use my jab
is because i'm trying to feel
distance out that means i'm trying to
set up multiple shots
so what i might start doing is firing my
jab out not with the intent to super
hurt him and for her and that'd be great
but my intent is a quick jab
so i touch him and i get i get i'm
getting right there right so i'm getting
right there okay and that's what i want
and then i use that to follow up with
combination shots
so once i know i can tap him with my jab
i know a cross and a hook might set up
immediately after right so
i'm here and i go bang bang bang and
it's hard to do all this on camera but
that's what i'm trying to do is i'm
using it to feel out distance i'm
setting a distance for myself so i can
continue boxing so
number one make distance number two set
distance and feel out distance that's
the second reason i might use a jab
third reason i would use a jab is to
fluster and frustrate my opponent right
so
that way they start making stupid
mistakes and i can get them exactly in
the way i want them right so i'm just
kind of
popping him around a lot so he starts
making bad choices and starts getting
frustrated
and that might be why i use a jab okay
aikido's answer
to a jab is always the same and that
answer is to
distance right so our proper my is this
it's impossible for anyone even if i
have super long arms right
um i can't jab josh from here right i
cannot jab josh from here
if josh could always maintain that
distance then i cannot
jab josh okay so what would i do as a
boxer
well i would try to creep in here and
get in
and then boom jab him now every time
josh sees me creeping
josh is not interested in aikido and
punching me back so every time josh sees
me creeping he creeps out
okay that's it right he creeps out okay
now look i can't jab him
impossible to jab him now that might not
seem and feel as cool as a kodagash
but tactically it's a great decision i
cannot jab him
if you are trying to always keep
distance it will be impossible for them
to jab you
and not only impossible but why would
they want to jab you
it's not doing their three objectives
right
so he doesn't need to make this i
wouldn't need to make distance with my
jab because he's already far away so i'm
not going to use it for that
i'm not going to use it to set distance
because it's not setting i'm not
touching him
so i might try to keep creeping up on
him but he's going to keep creeping out
i'm going to creep in he's going to
creep out and it's going to go on for a
long time
so that would be bad to use my jab to
set that distance that's bad and i'm not
going to fluster him with it because
he's not trying to come in to get me
he's not trying to set up his own shot
so i can't fluster and bother him with
my jab so
i'm just probably as a boxer not going
to use a jab in this situation
so that might make you say well yeah but
come on
what you're going to do is run him down
and then punch him and you're right
but running him down and punching him is
not a jab
running him down and punching him is not
a jab
okay now i'm saying this in this weird
way because look man
if i'm flustered and we'll go mega slow
so we can stay in frame
but if i'm flustered and i can't get a
jab i'm going to start to run at this
guy
to throw big shots at him that's what
i'm going to do because he won't stand
still for me to
jab him so i'm just never going to get a
jab off
so the jab is not really something in
aikido with aikido theory using proper
distancing we could said goodbye
that you're going to have to deal with
and a boxer wouldn't choose to use a jab
against you
now if i'm a mma guy i might run in to
grab you and then hit you all kinds of
things but that's not a jab it's not
what a jab is
so why are aikido people so obsessed
with doing
an aikido technique an ikea technique
off of a jab
because it's so cool
the reason is because it's so cool right
it's that simple it's so cool to do that
and it makes us feel as aikido people
like we're vindicated
the reason for that is the jab is the
number one punch in boxing right and you
know probably a lot of people could
disagree with that but in truth
the jab is used constantly in modern
boxing it's used tactically and
strategically all the time to do the
things that i listed that it can do
right
it bothers people it sets distance and
it makes distance right so it does all
those things really really nicely
so because it's so important to boxing a
jab is so important to boxing
aikido people think well if i could do
kodagaish off of
a jab then i would really be able to to
show that aikido can beat boxing and
that is
so cool
so we really have to to stop and set
ourselves aside and go like
am i really worried about being so
cool or am i actually
more worried about surviving a situation
or being able to handle myself or take
care of myself in
rough situations and if you want to
learn to box or wrestle you should do
that and so if you want to overcome
someone who's jabbing at you
learn to box learn to wrestle if you're
doing aikido the answer is real simple
you will never give them the distance to
jab so you might have to deal with other
kinds of punches and grappling stuff
but jabs is not really something you're
going to have to worry too much about
because it won't naturally come up in
the situations we're trying to do right
so
if they pin you against a wall or
something they'll hit you but those
aren't going to be jabs they're going to
be them
hitting you against a wall and we can
talk about that stuff in later series
okay now a really important question
last question you might say is well
then i guess uh coda guys is just stupid
right and so
why would we even have kodage why do we
even practice kodagaishi at all
um so let's take a second and look at
that and remember the reasons not
okay so aside from being so cool there's
a really good reason for something like
cottage
now it goes back to our historic
foundation right so what aikido
looked towards right so understand that
the techniques in aikido are not unique
those techniques can be found in kodu
jiu-jitsu that's old-fashioned jiu-jitsu
and they existed long before the founder
was born they're old school techniques
and they come from
war stuff right so what was happening on
a battlefield and people had
weapons on a battlefield right so they
had weapons okay now
that doesn't mean that it would be any
less valuable in today's world when
when today people also get upset and use
weapons to attack each other right and
the weapon might be a knife or a gun or
something also might just be a frying
pan or a vase or
whatever's handy that someone picks up
and wants to smash you with okay now
you could you can see logically that
josh could essentially
use the jab with a knife right so he
could jab at me
with that knife right so he's popping it
in popping it out right okay that's
great right
now as an aikido person again my initial
way of dealing with this is always to
set distance so i just want to stay at a
distance right
and he's trying to use that jab now it
would be nice if i could disarm
this guy now if we used my um
previous solutions for this which is
what i would use in mma or boxing right
now if i try to outbox this guy so even
imagine i'm a better boxer than josh and
so every time josh throws that
i beat him to the punch right i'm
beating to the punch do you see what's
happening
a he's got reach on me all of a sudden
right okay b
he's now killing me with this knife and
i'm just hitting him so you know maybe
i'm lucky and i knock him out but every
trade every time we trade shots
i am getting stabbed right and he's got
a reach advantage and a major power
advantage now that in a boxing situation
we wouldn't have so
if i'm trying to use my boxing skill to
beat a guy with a knife
and i'm trying to out jab him it's going
to be bad for me right so
so that's not a very good solution
trying to use boxing against a guy with
a knife
not the best you know it might work i
might get lucky and nail this guy
but if i don't get lucky i'm going to
get cut and even if i do get lucky and
knock him out i'm probably still going
to get cut and that might
might be bad for me later on okay now
how about an mma style
situation right which the idea is just
to slip that guy right so he comes in
and i'm just going to slip it i'm going
to get to this kind of position okay now
i can totally dump him
but watch what he's going to do with
that knife when i go to dump him right
that knife's going to start coming in to
to get me right so what i'll have to do
from that kind of position from that
kind of clinch
is immediately check the arm i would
slip it just like in
mma and then i would get to this kind of
position
and then i could i could do something
from here now
the ability to throw with code guys
didn't change just because he's got a
knife that didn't change
what did change is by doing the kodagash
i now
wrench the weapon out of his hand right
so what happened is whether he falls or
not and this might happen you know when
when i said oh you might say that like
oh it hurts so bad that they throw
themselves through the air he could it
could hurt so bad that he throws himself
through the air
but even if he doesn't what's happening
is i get a huge power advantage by
having both of my hands
on the weapon and turning the entire
entirety of my body around the weapon
and wrenching the weapon out of his hand
okay so
it's not really to try to throw his
whole body with this little wrist
it's to use the power of my whole body
to wrench the weapon out of his hand
and now we see kudagash has a really
good purpose
now catching it out of the air is still
going to be really challenging
but essentially following that knife in
and then being able to get a hold of it
or just like you would in mma
establish a basic clinch position and
then get to that knife hand from there
is what we would want to do so that's
why you would need coda guys
other ikea techniques will work the same
way right sankyo if we got in this
position
sankyo can work the same way right so i
can use tons and tons and tons of aikido
techniques
in that same way why would i need to do
them because there's something
of a priority in this hand right so
something that's going to kill me if i
don't take it out of this hand
so that's why i would do those kind of
techniques and that's where those
techniques come from
old school jiu jitsu which wasn't
worried about unarmed stuff it was
worried about armed stuff weapons so i
need to be able to control that weapon
so that's a whole picture of why you
really should stop trying to do
kodagaishi off a jab right
it's it's just it's a silly idea that we
don't need to have
now if we did it it would be so cool
but come on does anyone really care
no one really cares right so let's talk
about aikido in a practical sense and if
you want to be particularly marshall
right your iq is very marshall
then don't worry about trying to do it
off of a jab worry about how aikido fits
naturally in its own context
i'm christopher hine thanks for watching
bye